Let’s imagine we have a robot and we want
to position its gripper with respect to this
purple triangle and imagine that we want to
have the gripper directly above the centre
of the triangle and at a height something
like this.
So if we had a camera on the robot’s gripper,
it would see a view something like this. In
the particular view that the robot is seeing
from here, the pose of the gripper with respect
to the object is implicit. For instance, if
the robot gripper was initially in a position
like this, we can see that the image acquired
by the camera is quite different. So if we
could come up with a control algorithm that
would change the view from this to this, then
implicitly the robot is going to perform the
desired motion in the world coordinate frame.
Here’s a graphical representation of the
problem that we just discussed. We have the
initial view of the object. In this case,
our object is a triangle and it’s well-defined
by the coordinates of its three corners. This
is what the object looks like initially. But
I want the triangle to look like this in my
image.
It’s also well-defined by the coordinates
of its three corners. So we can define our
problem as changing the view of the object
from this to this. What we want to do is to
move the yellow circles to where the red circles
are. Just like this.
In order to move, these yellow circles need
to have some velocity. They need to have a
velocity towards the corresponding red circle.
So here is the coordinate of one of the yellow
circles and here is its velocity. It needs
to have this velocity, which would make it
move from where it is to where it needs to
go.
We’ve already discussed a relationship between
pixel velocity and camera velocity. It’s
given by the image Jacobian Matrix. We can
write the matrix as a function. I call it
Jp and that stands for Jacobian for a point
feature and it’s a function of the pixel
coordinate, u and v, also how far the point is away in the world, which is given by capital Z.
We refer to that as the depth of the point.
For three points, remember we have a point
on each corner of the triangle, we can describe
the velocity that we want point one to have,
point two to have and point three to have.
All that we’re doing is just stacking three
sets of equations, one above the other and
as a common factor, which is the camera velocity.
In the middle, we have a stack of these image
Jacobians. So for three points, the relationship
between the pixel velocities, camera velocity,
looks like this. This middle matrix, the stack
of image Jacobians, is now a six by six matrix.
Each of them is two by six. Stack three of
them on top of each other. The result is a
six by six matrix. Because this matrix is
square, we can invert it. We have a relationship
that looks like this. This is the desired
camera velocity. If the camera moved like
this, then all the points would have the desired
pixel velocity. They would move from where
they are, shown by the yellow circle, to where
you want them to be indicated by the red circle.
So this is a relationship between the velocity
that we want and the velocity that the camera
needs to have in order to make the change
in the image look like this. It’s computed
via the inverse of the stack of image Jacobian
matrices.
Let’s look now at how we might compute the
desired pixel velocity. We’re going to introduce
some extra notation. I’m going to use the
asterisk or star to indicate the desired value
of a quantity. So where we want the pixel
to be is indicated by U* and V* and where
it currently is, is indicated by the coordinate
U, V. So if I simply take the difference between
where I want it to be and where it is now
and multiply that by some arbitrary scale
factor lambda, I have an equation, which describes
the desired pixel velocity.
It’s a vector parallel to a line between
where I am and where I want to be. I use the
subscript “I” because this is a general
relationship that we can apply to any of the
corner points of our object. In this case,
it’s a triangular object so “I” varies
from one to three.
I introduce a bit more notation. I use the
symbol “P” which is a vector to represent
the coordinate of a point and substituting
that into the previous relationship, now I
have an expression that tells me the desired
velocity of the camera as indicated by this
star subscript is equal to lambda, an arbitrary
game, multiplied by the inverse of the stack
of image Jacobians, multiplied by another
vector which is made up of a difference between
where the point is and where I’d like the
point to be.
Let’s have a look at a simulation of this.
On the left, we have a simulated image plane.
So the circles indicate where the object is
currently projected and the asterisks indicate
where it is that I would like those points
to be projected to. The asterisks are the
destination coordinates. On the right hand
side, we have a 3D view of what’s going
on. The three red spheres indicate the points
in three-dimensional space, the corners of
the triangle. In blue, we have a simple 3D
representation of a camera with an attached
camera coordinate frame.
When I start the simulation, we can see that
the camera is moving towards the three points
in the world and initially it moves quite
quickly and then slows down.
This is a characteristic of the proportional
controller that we’re using demonstrates
asymptotic convergence and we can see that
the circles, the current view of those world
points on the image plane moving slowly but
surely towards the desired goals.
What’s happened is by simply specifying
what needs to happen on the image plane that
this coordinate needs to move to this coordinate,
in the real world, in the three-dimensional
world, the task has been completed. The camera
has moved to a desired pose.
But notice in achieving that task, we haven’t
had to say anything about the pose of the
camera or the pose of the objects in the real
world. This whole task has been completed
simply by driving to zero the error on the
image plane.
This is an important characteristic of what
we call image-based visual servoing.
Let’s look at a concrete example here. This
is my MATLAB workspace which I've initialized
with a few variables.
I've created a camera object with the default
settings we've seen before. I've defined the
vertices of a triangle in world coordinates
and they’re represented by the columns of
the matrix “P” and I have created a homogeneous
transformation which represents the pose of
the camera within the world space and I've
done that by defining a position and rotation
around the X, Y and Z axes given by this homogeneous
transformation here.
So I can plot the projection of the world
points on to the image plane, using the plot
method of the camera object, parse in the
coordinates of the three world points, the
columns of the matrix P and I’m going to
tell the object that the camera pose is at
this variable here, T-cam. Now we see the
projection of those three points on the image
plane. We can see that the camera is some
distance away from the triangle and it’s
looking at the triangle somewhat obliquely.
The plot method has returned the projections
on the image plane and they’re given by
the columns of the matrix little b. Now I
can compute an image Jacobian from these three
points. I do that by again using the visjac_p
method, visual Jacobian for point features
and I’m going to parse in the point features,
little p and this contains three points and
I’m going to specify that all the points
are five meters away from the camera.
This is not strictly true. I don’t actually
know how far away the points are but for the
moment bare with me and we’ll just put in
the number five.
Now we have the visual Jacobian’s for each
of the three points. Each point has a two
by six image Jacobian and now they’re all
stacked up so the result is a six by six matrix
in the workspace. This is a matrix that I
could invert. It’s a square matrix. If I
use this matrix to multiply a vector of desired
image plane velocities, the result will be
the spatial velocity that the camera needs
in order to achieve that.
So in summary, image-based visual servoing
is all about describing a task in terms of
how we want points to move in the image. We
then construct a simple controller that moves
the camera so as to create the point motion
that we require.
As the points move from where they are now
to where we’d like them to be, the useful
task is achieved in the 3D world. But the
task is not described in terms of pose of
objects or of the robot. The task is in fact implicit in the motion that we require on the image plane.
In some ways, we’re talking about relative
motion of the camera. We’re steering the
camera towards the goal location. It’s not
defined in terms of absolutes. We don’t
need to know the pose of the camera or the
pose of the objects with respect to any kind
of world coordinate frame.
This technique works really well in this particular
case where we have got three points in the
scene. It doesn't work for just one or two
points and it’s much more complex in a case
where we have four or more points.
It’s certainly doable but a little more complicated and beyond the scope of this particular lecture.